an ai is now officially listed as the
inventor in a patent
alef alpha raises 27 million dollars to
build europe's open ai
and an open source replication of dali
is released
welcome to ml news
all right before we get into all the
stuff this video is sponsored by
weight and biases weights and biases is
a one-stop
shop for machine learning researchers to
track their experiments
save their models recreate their old
experiments
uh share work with others and generally
analyze their results
weights and biases allows you with one
single line of code
to track your experiments which means
that weights and biases
will track the execution run of your
experiment
it will track the results it will track
saved models and checkpoints
upload it all to a convenient central
place
in your profile and that allows you to
analyze
visualize all of your experiments and
data think of it like
effortless tensorboard in the cloud
weights and biases has
integrations across all of the deep
learning frameworks pytorch tensorflow
hogging phase you name it
they probably have an integration
available today i want to tell you about
a new feature that they have which is
called
tables now the name is deceptively
simple
uh table is simply a grid of stuff
but in weights and bias these tables
allow you to view
things like data sets but also outputs
of your runs any kind of artifact you
have
you can analyze in tables tables allow
you
to sort group filter and do anything
with the data you're looking at and you
can take advantage of all the
visualization capabilities that you're
used to
from weights and biases dashboards for
example
here we automatically visualize the
results
of pixel level annotations i mean look
at that left hand side
that model sucks look at the bottom why
is the sky
labeled as trees clearly you have to do
something here so as you can see you can
analyze the output of your runs you can
see where the model still makes mistakes
by filtering
for the samples that are classified
incorrectly
if for some reason weights and biases
doesn't have a visualization for
your type of data which is unlikely if
they don't have it they allow you to
actually integrate with their framework
in order to produce one the capabilities
here are really endless here you can see
we
visualize anything from sound files to
training plots to spectrograms whatever
you can think of
so as a special bonus viewers of this
channel only
get 80 off today of the basic plan
which you don't need actually because
it's free yes it's completely free
there's really nothing stopping you from
going there and making an account
personal accounts free unlimited
experiments
if you're a bit more involved if you
want a team and
if that team is large and does a lot of
tracking you'll have to give them some
money but their main income
comes from big enterprises that want to
use this
internally if you are such a big
enterprise don't hesitate
to give them a call and give them a lot
of money in that way you'll be
supporting all the free accounts for
all us plebs there are special options
for academic research teams which do
get free team accounts and you can also
self-host if you need to be compliant
with
some sort of regulations so again go
over to weights and biases and check it
out there's a lot of features that i
haven't even talked about yet such as
hyper parameter optimization that's done
automatically
check it out and now let's get into the
news
[Music]
i'm back yay what did i miss what has
been going on how do i do how do i do
news
i forgot all right the global legal post
rights south africa issues world's first
patent listing ai
as inventor so this person right here is
professor ryan abbott he and his legal
team
have been fighting around the world
applying for patents that list
the ai named davos as the inventor of
two particular inventions so now they
finally succeeded in south africa
and also as abc news writes an
australian court has
equally ruled that ai can be listed as
an inventor on a patent application
now the situation is a little bit
complex and i'm not a lawyer so don't
take my word for it but the ownership of
the patent
rests with the creator of davis of the
ai
while davos is listed as the inventor so
here's one of the
things that dabbas apparently invented
it's kind of a fractal thing so they're
saying this
is kind of a food container or something
and the
fractality somehow makes it good and you
can connect containers together
but there's also this uh light emitting
thing that has kind of a
fractalish pulse or something that makes
it really noticeable and this here
is stephen taller who is the inventor of
davos and therefore
the owner of the patent now i was
immensely
interested into this and i have spent
way too much time researching this here
is kind of a few takeaways
first i thought this is a pr stunt come
on you know why can't you just list
yourself
as an inventor because ultimately ai is
like a tool right and how does an ai
even come up with new ideas like what
counts as new ideas and
like how does an ai come up with this
or or this like what was the part that
the ai did
what was the starting point what was it
do it like i'm so confused okay
so this is the website of the team of
the legal professionals that
got the patents through to through the
courts and they answer
some of these questions and their claim
here is that in the various legal
systems
the granting of a patent requires the
inventor to perform like the
invention step like there's a specific
step in the conception of an
of an idea that is like the innovative
step and
it is actually criminal offense to list
the
wrong individual as an inventor so the
inventor does the creative step
and you have to list that person as the
inventor otherwise it's criminal offense
now the question is if legally the ai
did that inventive step whatever that
means
technically you should list the ai there
because you can't list any of your your
employees
you can't list yourself because you've
only controlled and built the ai but the
ai did the actual step that the law
requires to be listed
under the inventor and apparently they
claim
at places patent applications have been
rejected
because of this so from this perspective
it kind of makes sense
that you should be able to list the ai
as the inventor now counter to that
some legal systems also reject this
notion saying only a natural person can
be an inventor and therefore
on some of these inventions simply no
patent can be granted
which would be discouraging from
researching stuff
remember ai is used to make inventions
in such field as drug discovery where
the ai simply
comes up with new compounds and then you
test them so in a way the inventive step
is performed by the ai
if you could not apply for a patent in
that that would discourage research
in these directions all right so this
seemed to me like to be a reasonable
explanation but that's
only the surface right here i was much
more interested in the question of
how how does this system that i have
never heard of
come up with new invention and here on
this hideous website of this legal team
this question
appears to be answered and cut uh
so this has gotten so long through the
edits
that it just completely blows the format
of ml news
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
cut the rest of this
into its own video because this is
really weird this davos system is weird
this whole case is weird
the too long didn't read is there might
be
a valid legal reason why ai needs to be
listed as an inventor on a patent
also at the same time this is probably a
giant pr
stunt and the inventions themselves
aren't they're nothing
so uh you know look forward to the next
video
make up your own mind let's go on with
the news
all right german startup olive alpha
raises
27 million us dollar series a round to
build europe's open ai
from techcrunch this is jonas andrulis
the founder of
aleph alpha with headquarters in
heidelberg in germany which is not too
far from here and the goal is to
build the equivalent of open ai but in
a european fashion so it says the german
ai startup out of alpha has now
raised 23 million euro which is
27 million in real money in a series a
founding
co-led by early bird vc lake star and
ubc
partners the team says it will have a
strong commitment to
open source communities such as luther
ai academic partnerships and will be
pushing european values and ethical
standards it says supporting
fairer access to modern ai research
aimed at
counteracting the ongoing
de-democratization
monopolization and loss of control or
transparency
so while these are laudable goals and i
really hope they
achieve and stick to these goals
remember that
openai has said the same at the
beginning and now openai
is mostly interested in closing down
access to their stuff
and charging for it but luckily venture
capitalists which are the main founders
of this venture right here
are not known to ever wanting their
money back or anything like this
so this should just be a breeze for
olive alpha
so i wish jonas and co-founder samwell
and
anyone part of aleph alpha all the best
big success in their endeavors it's
going to be fun having sort of a counter
force to
the us here in europe
[Music]
robotics 24 7 says amp robotics marks
milestone in data
pick rates for automated recycling so
speaking of companies and raising money
this company is now raising series b
for about 55 million us dollars and
they're in the space of
garbage sorting and disposal
and recycling so they've developed these
analysis
and gripper technologies and this is
incredibly cool to watch
i mean we're always talking about ai
taking away our jobs
i don't think people will be too sad
that ai is going to take away their jobs
in this particular field so here the ai
automatically analyzes the streams of
garbage and sorts them by the materials
in them and sorry these blocks of cans
just look really cool
also there is such a thing as waste expo
didn't know
excellent must be a blast
next news deepmind releases a paper
called open-ended learning leads to
generally capable
agents so what they do is they build an
environment called
x-land this is kind of a 3d environment
and the agents in here you can see
on the top left and top right this is
what they see apparently
and they have to fulfill various goals
in these environments
you can build any kind of environment
you want in x-land then you can
tell the agents to achieve that
apparently the paper is about
when you instruct the agents to learn
multiple goals
many goals at the same time or after one
another
they become generally capable as opposed
to just
having a single objective and then
ending up with a very narrow skilled
agent now ex-land can be used to not
only
have many different environment
spatially but also have many different
tasks or games in this environment so
they have capture the flag king of the
hill
and so on in the paper they actually
detail how they use population based
methods in order to train these agents
how good they are at zero shop learning
and so on
and this is all pretty cool however
these things and results aren't that
new we already knew that population
based training is probably good if you
want to
achieve some generally skilled agents we
already knew that multi-objective or
objective conditioned learning is
probably a good thing
ultimately the agents here are simply an
observation encoder into an lstm
and then they take in the goal
conditioning and then it's a standard
actor critic reinforcement learning i
guess what i want to say is that the
research isn't necessarily
super new or exciting but you can get a
lot lot of publicity if you build
something
that's 3d and looks really cool so
if you want you can build your own stuff
in ex-land
if you work at deepmind because i don't
think it's open source
so haha the new york times
writes something bothering you tell it
to
robot and it is about the system that
delivers cognitive behavioral therapy
through an app so cognitive behavioral
therapy is one of the more successful
approaches to treat things like
depression or anxieties
it is rather formulaic as this article
describes and therefore
it lends itself at least a little bit to
be
incorporated into some kind of algorithm
so the article
is a discussion of is this good is this
bad the pros are that usually a human
therapist is very expensive and
there aren't enough of them especially
in times of a
global health crisis on the other hand
critics argue that these algorithms
aren't yet good enough to replace a
human
because they cannot intrinsically
understand the things that the humans
say
and you get the idea the new york times
accompanies this person right here eli
who has tried out the app for
a given period of time eli details how
the app sometimes fails responding to my
boss doesn't appreciate the work
i do and i can't seem to get her
approval the bot answers with that
sounds difficult does this happen more
in the morning or at night it is a
little bit of an improvement i guess
over something like
eliza however it still seems to be
rather
formulaic so my own personal opinion is
this
if i have some problems there are books
that i can read self-help books that
guide me
through the process of somehow solving
my own problems these books are
necessarily impersonal they are written
by a person
but they're not personalized to me in
any way it's the same text
for every single person that buys the
book so
if a book like this can help me then
certainly
a little bit of an algorithmized version
of a book
like this might help me too you know
there are ways to
make it worse but i don't think much so
if you
think that there are good books that
have helped you in the past
to overcome personal issues or problems
or any kind of improvement
then it's entirely possible that an app
like this does the same thing i don't
think we have to
necessarily seek to replace therapists
but there are a lot of people who cannot
afford therapists
or don't have one close by and in this
case such an app can probably help
of course it's also easy to see that
people will feel as though that actually
replaces a competent therapist and not
seek the
attention of an actual therapist when
it's needed so at the end eli breaks up
with robot
saying he was unimpressed by the bot's
advice for beating back loneliness and
despair but he is not entirely sorry
that he tried it out the mere act of
typing out his problems was helpful and
through the process he pinpointed what
he actually needed to feel better
yes so it worked now eli is seeing a
human therapist in philadelphia for 110
dollars a session
next news synced writes google's
wordcraft text editor advances human ai
collaborative story writing so the text
editor isn't out yet
just a paper and a demo video where
a human writes something and then clicks
on a button and then the machine sort of
continues
the story this seems to be sort of a gpt
three-ish
thing with an interface that just helps
you select from different continuations
and does the prompt engineering in a
smart way for you you can even customize
the prompt you can ask the model to
elaborate
on particular parts of the story and
then
choose from various continuation i think
that's pretty cool if it
ever will appear online which i'm not
sure
uh given that it's google but if it ever
will appear something like this
might lead humans to just come up with
new ideas through
this thing so pretty cool
[Music]
next news pc mag rights machine learning
is now being used to cheat in
multiplayer games
so there's apparently this video here
that demonstrates
that a bot is used for cheating in games
now aimbots have been a thing for a
while but apparently this thing
works in a little bit of a different way
and it also works on consoles which
for now has been a kind of a difficult
thing for aimbots so what you do is you
hook up your console
to a video capture card feed that into
your pc and the pc would actually
send commands to your controller so
you'd hold the controller
but your controls would sort of be
overwritten at times
by the input of the cheat engine and
that makes
detecting these cheats rather hard to
use
now it just says that machine learning
is used in order
to control this right here you could
also imagine this being just kind of a
classic aimbot that just recognizes some
pixels and then
shoots at it but apparently it's machine
learning based so
you know it's in ml news thanks
[Music]
next news google releases the open
buildings
data set which is a data set that across
satellite images of africa has
annotations of over
516 million buildings this goes along
with a paper where they detail the
challenges that they had to overcome to
do this
so you can devise various failure modes
right here so all of these pictures for
examples are
not buildings the top left are water
pools top rider
rocks then here there are some buildings
but the thing in the red square is not a
building it's just a bunch of walls
the left are containers this is very
difficult
google has annotated over i think a
million images 1.75 million
images or sorry google has annotated
1.75 million buildings in 100 000 images
by hand and then trained a system on it
the paper details
how difficult that was how much you have
to use augmentation and regularization
in order to do that but in the end
they've come up with this giant data set
that you can now use you can actually
explore the data set
in this interactive explorer right here
so you can switch between
this view which is i'm not sure how
helpful that is or this view
i have discovered so if you zoom in
right here
i have discovered however that sometimes
i feel
at least like this piece here is this
an actual building it says it's a very
high confidence building
i'm not sure honestly also this thing
here this might be one but it seems like
it works pretty well
just overall the challenges are also
recognizing
buildings in both rural areas where they
kind of blend into the environment and
recognizing buildings
in commercial or dense populated areas
where
you mainly have to separate buildings
from each other so pretty cool give the
open buildings data set a try
if you're interested
[Music]
next mit technology review writes
hundreds of ai tools have been built to
catch covet none of them helped
yet another article about the
shortcomings of machine learning
research and the take of this article is
somehow
you know more effort is needed and
criticizing ml research in the meantime
i have a bit of a more cynical approach
right here like
we've known long enough about the
publication pressure in
ml research and to use a buzzword topic
like kovid in order to get a paper
published by simply applying
whatever your thing is in research
whatever your topic is
and using it on some kind of code data
set in order to get a publication out of
it because people think like oh this is
you know relevant we need to publish
fast now
i don't think the main motivation of 99
of this research was actually to develop
something that actually
works old methods are slapped onto new
topics in order to get publications
and we will continue to see that in the
future as well
don't expect any of these things to work
in the first place
[Music]
next news dolly mini is an open source
replication effort of open ai's dali
so these people have built a version of
dali that is much smaller but
has first signs of actually working
remember dali goes from text to
images and you can actually try it out
yourself
on an online interactive demo on hogging
face here's my query for creepy clown
and the model does not disappoint it
seems like there's still
a gap probably a gap in size model size
and data set size
until this project reaches the level of
dali if ever but still
it's pretty cool and i love the avocado
chair just as much as the dolly one
[Music]
okay we come to the helpful library
section of ml news
helpful libraries first helpful library
is kind of big news
openai releases triton which is a
language that allows you to build custom
kuda kernels
and these cuda kernels are super duper
duper fast
and you don't have to know low level c
plus cuda in order to produce them
so there's a blog post and code to go
along with it
detailing in in very detail what's now
possible with triton
and apparently openai has made this in
such a way
that people who have no previous
experience with
cuda programming are able to produce
kernels
that are as fast or faster than
the kernels that were previously
programmed by
experienced cuda programmers so if you
have
something that doesn't have a efficient
cuda kernel
yet maybe give triton a try next helpful
library
flammel fast and lightweight auto ml is
a library for cost effective hyper
parameter optimization so apparently
you enter your problem to optimize and
your cost
and the library will optimize your hyper
parameter towards your cost taking
into account how much each hyper
parameter setting costs to explore so
for example if you have something like
model size as a hyper parameter
it will preferably try the smaller sizes
first because they cost less and you can
search more before it then scales up
that hyper parameter
pretty cool give it a try next up for
library italian clip remember
clip scores images and text together and
italian clip is now available
particularly it can classify such things
as a
and oh i'm kidding it's uh it's a cool
project
check it out if you are italian speaking
or building italian
speaking products next helpful library
deepmind releases melting pot and
evaluation suite
for multi-agent reinforcement learning
now other than excellent this one is
actually open
it's an environment in deepmind 2d lab
and has various scenarios
for multi-agent reinforcement learning
and this actually looks like
you can do some research with it and
multi-agent reinforcement learning
especially something like cooperative
multi-agent reinforcement learning is
one of these areas that is still
largely unexplored and we don't have
super good algorithms for it yet so if
you're looking for some research
to do this might be a cool topic there's
an old helpful library with some news
mojoco the 3d simulator that has been
used for a long time
for doing things like continuous
reinforcement learning control problems
and so on is
now free the product requires a license
but they do give out
a free license to anyone at least until
the 31st of october 2021.
so if the availability of the license
has blocked you so far
give it a try now also in rl news
openai gym has a new maintainer that is
going to address the poll requests that
are there
project has been kinda dead for a long
time and
the new maintainer makes it clear that
there aren't going to be new
environments
uh major breaking changes environment
wrappers anything like this
i think they simply want to make the gym
usable and up-to-date as it is pretty
cool
if you're a gym user this should give
you some stability and compatibility
with current libraries the new
maintainer is jk terry
thanks for your work so in last news for
today the free software foundation
calls for white papers on the
philosophical and legal questions around
copilot
apparently they're contacted
understandably a lot with regards to
copilot
and the kind of legal ramifications of
copyright and patents
in what copilot does if you don't know
what co-pilot is
watch ml news from a while ago in
essence they give you 500 bucks if you
publish a paper through them that
somehow
elaborates on part of these topics so
areas of interest
are is co-pilot training on public
repositories infringing copyright
is it fair use how likely is the output
of copal to generate actionable claims
of violations on gpa licensed works
and so on so there are some submission
guidelines and i wonder if there's a way
i can submit my ml news segment to this
where's my 500 bucks richard come on so
the criticism of the free software
foundation is that copilot is
what they call service as a software
substitute
which is a term they came up with to
replace saas
software as a service to make it more
clear of course
richard stallman here writes the basic
point is you can have control over a
program
someone else wrote if it's free but you
can never have control over a service
someone else runs
so never use a service where in
principle
running a program would do never richard
says
never ok new.org let's look at that
a certificate what kind of certificate
is there
hmm details it's by let's encrypt
g is let's encrypt a program or a
service
i wonder what's up richard you're
perfectly capable of generating ssl
certificates using openssl
a free program that you can run yet you
elect to use a service like let's
encrypt well isn't that a jolly
alright this was already way too long
this was it for this week's ml news
please check out weights and biases
they're a great system
and i'll see you next time bye bye